[Musique]
et allez-y luis dois tu veux mon chéri
ça va être la folie soir
[Musique]
s'ils savaient ce qu'ils devaient bombe
atomique à d'autres thèmes évoqués dans
la villa d'un domaine
ouais c'est mécanique ou kido en tout
cas laissé nimani 200 km et elle est
moyen 59e minute sur le coup même salle
où ses débuts son soutien est ce normal
de l'eau normale sur les autres a
expliqué thomas glocer
jje pas si tort surtout claude elfassi
temps
commence alors
dans la quête au micro
ce pas
non
[Musique]
savoure encore
mais
tous ont assez
[Musique]
est à cidre par mois selon la presse
walter rigaud attaqué la solde des
ténèbres didot ballack émis 6 2 6 4
[Musique]
bien sûr
je ne pense pas
et sinon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
luiz qui va être avec nous toutes les
missions et c'est une énorme star big
big star qui est avec nous aujourd'hui